la tercera noche de la convención
demócrata giró en torno a una figura la
de la candidata demócrata a la
vicepresidencia
kamala harris quien aceptó su cargo
harris es la primera mujer negra en
aspirar a la vicepresidencia con un gran
partido y la tercera mujer en la
historia aunque hasta ahora ninguna lo
ha conseguido en su discurso defendió
una candidatura que una a todos los
estadounidenses
podemos hacerlo mejor merecemos mucho
más where we must a light presión
debemos elegir un presidente que nos
ofrezca algo diferente algo mejor
y que haga el trabajo importante un
presidente que nos una a todos negros
blancos latinos asiáticos indígenas para
conseguir el futuro que queremos
colectivamente
el tema migratorio fue clave durante la
jornada donde tomó protagonismo el ex
presidente barack obama dando voz a un
vídeo que enfatizó la importancia de la
inmigración en eeuu y el origen de todos
los estadounidenses la política
migratoria de donald trump fue duramente
criticada y se mostró el caso de una
niña a la que han deportado a su madre
un legado que fue muy cuestionado por
obama and mars nunca esperé que mi
sucesor adoptará mi misión o continuará
con mis políticas
si espere por el bien de mi país que
donald trump mostrará algo de interés en
tomarse en serio el trabajo
primer cambio que llegara a sentir el
peso del despacho y encontrará algo de
reverencia por la democracia que se
ponía en su cuidado pero nunca lo
encontró brinda volver durante la
ceremonia virtual tomaron protagonismo
otras figuras importantes como hillary
clinton que destacó la importancia del
voto por correo o la presidenta de la
cámara de representantes nancy pelosi